as an opposing quarterback it's so
frustrating to watch him on the field
because it's third and 15. it doesn't
matter like he could first and 10 turn
15 basically the same thing you know
like
making plays with his feet I mean there
was a couple times he was sack in the
backfield but then he wasn't you know
and he's finding a way to get out and
he's out running everybody but some of
his throws he made the other day too
were unbelievable some second window
throws I mean around Tremaine only where
his guy can get it
um the dude's a baller and there's only
a few really few guys in the league like
that it doesn't matter what down or
distance it is like they've always got a
chance and he's one of those guys and
um you know I said this last week and I
know you've said it like he's up next
for that contract like it's he's going
to be the guy he's going to be the
highest paid guy and that's kind of how
how the league Works
um but he's he's betting on himself
right now and
I mean it's he's playing playing
fantastic football and
um Above All Else Like You can tell how
teammates respond to a guy yeah right
I'm saying they are rally around them
you know he just has this unique ability
to make his teammates around him play
better than what they normally would be
and I know he has a team full of Ballers
but he just all the great leaders like
you like you know all the other great
quarterbacks Lamar they just have this
knack to
rise up like have their teammates rise
up to a level that they wouldn't
normally play and I know I said
something about his contract too like
you want guys to get paid like you want
guys to be the highest paid ever because
that just lifts the floor for everybody
else and then you'll be back up again
and you got to get another one right
here so you know I always been an
advocate of guys getting paid like and
especially like a girl a guy like Lamar
Jackson he's done everything under the
sun that you could possibly do to put
himself in great position for the next
contract and he even took it a step
further you know a betting on himself
and the price is is only going up it's
it's only going up and everybody around
the league should want him to get paid
because once you get paid he gets paid
then it rises it helps rise the pass
versus contracts you got you got Michael
Parsons and all these guys coming up and
it rises up the the wide receivers
contract and the offensive line and then
everybody that has to go against these
guys so I'm always a big advocate for
guys getting paid